still so many unknowns but here's one
thing we do know the state hardest hit
by the coronavirus is extending orders
to stay at home New York will remain
largely shut down until at least May
15th there are signs that social
distancing measures are working there
but the crisis is far from over and
millions are still in danger our lead
national correspondent David Begg know
is in an eerily quiet Time Square David
good morning
so May 15th what else you learning well
Tony that the governor's statements
about being able to better control the
spread of the virus is bearing out to be
true when you walk into some hospitals
around the state we went to one in
Nassau County yesterday right outside
New York City and they are no longer
overwhelmed the caseload is much more
manageable now in Nassau County if you
set aside New York City excluding the
city
Nassau County has more cases and deaths
than any other county in America so I
want you to take a look at what we saw
at the hospital so this is our triage
what we saw inside of North Shore
Hospital on Long Island appears to echo
what we've been hearing from New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo ICU admissions
number is also down significantly for
the first time it's welcome news some
200 people have died inside of this
hospital alone from kovat 19 but we were
told that over the last 72 hours they
have actually discharged more
coronavirus patients than they've
admitted in New Jersey the Andover
subacute and Rehabilitation Center
confirms that 15 bodies were held and
the majority removed from a holding room
Monday the deaths are believed to be
related to kovat 19 the nursing home
says that has been working relentlessly
to contain the virus and safeguard our
residents and staff the health and
safety of our residents and staff is our
utmost priority and responsibility
franceska Veen says her grandmother is
living there but says no one in the
family was told that the facility had
kovat 19 positive patients I am sick
and tired of being told they cannot talk
to her around the country coronavirus
patients are dying alone families cannot
visit them but in Louisiana a hospice
has opened believed to be the first
dedicated to terminally ill kovat 19
patients where families are allowed
carnelian Garcia spent much of yesterday
at the bedside of his father Willy free
low I'm really grateful like I get to
see the man that raised me you know kind
of raised me you know that brought me in
this world I can still you know it's bad
next to them you mean they my P before
you go the organization heart of hospice
has set up inside of East Jefferson
General Hospital in Metairie Louisiana
here to family members per day are given
PPE and allowed to be present at the
bedside the nurses help connect those
who can't be here Louisiana's governor
says hospitalizations are declining in
the New Orleans region which is a
hotspot for Kovac cases and is now where
compassionate care guarantees that
patients will not die alone
part of hospice provided us with the
video of course with the permission of
the family and you know Anthony one of
the most haunting things about this
vicious disease is the thought that so
many family members are dying alone and
so for those families in Louisiana to
die with their loved ones at their side
it's really a game changer and it means
so much to those families yeah I can
imagine David that is it's one of the
really toughest parts of this whole
thing for families thank you